Charlie is in Orlando Florida hi Charlie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I did I
go today
better than I deserve what's up all
right um
situation is we're trying to get on base
step one with my wife and I and we
currently have three vehicles uh two of
them are paid for uh the two they're
paid for our right now our daily drivers
one of the Noldor pickup and the third
car we have is not paid for and we oh uh
about 8500 on it why do you have 40 cars
uh college kids I know okay kids in high
school and it'll just you know pour on I
got you uh sure what's your household
income uh we're looking at around 120
130 a year why you broke uh bad choices
okay we bought a well by the house last
year we did washroom all in on it and uh
got carried away okay write your
questions what sir
uh so Ellen on stillness one car has a
debt on it that it's not paid for uh we
owe eighty five hundred on it
it's we can probably sell it for about
twelve thirteen thousand I want to sell
it and put the money towards our baby
steps getting young thousand dollars
they step one and how much debt you have
not killing your house uh we're looking
at um about twenty thousand and credit
but the the car is the car a property
five hundred you know these the credit
cards or twenty thousand what you meant
yes okay alright and what else and about
20,000 401k loans mm-hmm anything else
uh no that's that's about it okay so you
make one hundred thirty thousand dollars
a year and basically we're saying
$48,500 makes you debt free but not
counting your house right
how many kids do you have uh we still
have one at home and how many are in
college too are you paying for that
uh no not really
who's paying for it uh I think they got
a student loans I believe are they your
kids I know they're my wives remind the
college stepchildren I see their
elevator they did they did you raise
them do they live with you uh we have
for about the past five years I see okay
well what would be wrong with keeping
the car and rolling up your sleeves and
getting on a beans and rice rice and
beans budget and as you said reverse the
bad decisions start making good
decisions living on a very frugal budget
and using your wonderful income to clean
up the forty eight thousand dollars in
debt systematically over the next say
year and a half two years maybe twenty
four thousand a year out of a hundred
and thirty thousand would be debt-free
in two years right that's very doable
prove a probably should happen sooner
what would be wrong with that plan uh
not much I guess I just look and see why
we need really need three cars and the
fact I'm getting my dad cut kids using
the other cars know the two uh um
they're they're off in college away from
home so you don't need three cars yeah I
don't need three cars and actually in
December I'm I am getting a classic car
that I was doing my aunt gave me for a
birthday present and the 69 Firebird so
I had look at having four cars in the
garage at one time so you need to get
rid of them anyway huh yeah okay and so
who's driving the car with the eight
thousand five hundred dollar debt you
were your wife I was it was my daily
driver
um and then once I decided I want her
heard my stepdaughter went to college I
decided to think about selling it trying
to get out of debt and I've been driving
my pickup so I not summed up putting
mileage on so it's been sitting yeah
it's not your wife's car you're trying
to sell her car no I'm not trying to
sell her car alright
that's not the one she's been driving I
mean okay well if it's sitting you know
sell it and you don't need another car
yeah salad I got no problem with that um
what's the question about that
or does somebody shot one seller does he
thinks we should sell it but get a get
get another third car why and I'll just
explain to me why you don't need another
car why would she think you need a car
uh for for a daily driver she let me
drive my pickup because the gas mileage
okay thank you she thinks we should sell
it get another car you know the you know
six or seven thousand you know America
you'd have to drive your the car to the
moon and back to make that up on gas
mileage yeah mathematically that doesn't
work right that's like people who buy a
hybrid for forty thousand bucks to save
on gas correct it's just it's
mathematically stupid yeah I mean if you
want to save on gas that's fine but
don't tell me the math works on it
because you can't drive the car enough
to get the money back for the car with
the gas mileage savings in your life you
can't drive it that much you see what
I'm saying
oh yes I realize yeah when you run the
math that doesn't work so I mean I I'm I
don't know what the negotiation is here
I don't understand I it's no it's a dumb
idea
and so yeah sell your car that's sitting
in the garage drive your old truck while
you get out of debt and you guys need to
get on a plan where you quit buying crap
and start selling crap instead and get
things cleaned up here and written
written budget that you and your wife
are in agreement on that is sacrificial
and it cuts your lifestyle to the bone
so that you can clean this mess up
you might make a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars a year you know you've
been married for five years and you're
broke something needs to change dude
that's the point this is the Dave Ramsey
show